[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
assurance chômage les apports du Sénat
au deuxième trimestre 2022 2,3 millions
de personnes étaient au chômage dans
notre pays soit 7,4% de la population
active dans ce contexte le projet de loi
portant mesure d'urgence relative au
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi vise à faire évoluer
en profondeur l'assurance chômage
après avoir enrichi le texte initial les
sénateurs sont parvenus mardi 8 novembre
2022 à un compromis avec les députés
dans le cadre de la commission mixte
paritaire
l'accord trouvé reprend de nombreux
apports du Sénat avant tout il répond à
la volonté du Sénat de reposer une
question fondamentale celle de la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage une
négociation interprofessionnelle sur la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage aura
lieu qui portera notamment sur
l'équilibre financier du régime et
l'opportunité de maintenir le document
de cadrage en complément les députés et
les sénateurs se sont mis d'accord sur
de nouvelles incitations à accepter un
CDI dans un contexte de fortes tensions
sur le marché du travail
désormais la location chômage sera
supprimée après deux refus de CDI à
l'issue de contrats à durée déterminée
ou de mission d'intérim
enfin le Sénat a marqué le texte de son
empreinte en posant le principe de
l'ouverture de la validation des acquis
de l'expérience à toute personne dont
l'expérience est en lien avec la
certification visée
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]